[Musique]
le
ans
les gens autorités disent toi tu es pas
capable de faire ça toi voilà c'était ça
le souci
en fin de compte avec ce pas capable
masai démontré que nous les quand même
capable pas capable mais un peu moins
même maladie pas capable et moi ça
essayez vous réveiller quels conseils
donneriez vous à quelqu'un doivent aux
plus jeunes que vous qui serait dans
benghazi dure qu il faudrait lui dire
que son doute c'est pas facile tous les
jours on a envie à chaque moment
d'abandonner mais il faut se dire ça va
aller 1 demain c'est un autre jour il
faut y aller quoi enfin faux pas faut
pas lâcher et puis faut s'entourer de
gens positifs constamment et qui veulent
vous pousser
aller de l'avant moi j'ai vu plein de
personnes en fauteuil roulant ou même
trisomique et touba ils travaillent ils
s'en sortent bien ils sont heureux donc
rien n'est impossible de dire tant qu'on
a la volonté on peut y aller il faut
savoir que beaucoup d'entreprises
préfèrent payer des les amendes des
indemnités parce qu'ils sont épinglés il
n'arrive pas aussi pour cent nous mêmes
au sein de l'espace réglé je remettrais
en lui mit à l'atelier canal j font un
travail je dirais remarquable puisque il
rénove du mobilier du conseil
départemental qui vont véritablement un
patrimoine réunionnais il rénove les
chaises créole ils refont le cannage
eto'o ces photos là arrivent chez nous
d'un état lamentable des fois ils sont
restés pendant des années dans un coin
de couloir et aujourd'hui grâce à cet
atelier là ces fauteuils là sont re re
re mis en valeur dans les différents
services du conseil départemental dans
les quatre points de lille
et c'est vraiment un patrimoine
réunionnais qui sauvegarder
bienvenue ça fait quatre ans je
travaille ici j'ai été formé par le chef
du jeu depuis remercie que ce que c'est
vraiment un travail de patience que que
j'adore faire moi la passion j'en dis à
vous vendre il faut bosser les personnes
handicapées ils sont bien il ya
plusieurs handicaperait je veux dire moi
je suis handicapé je suis je suis debout
sur la vie personnelle ne collait suis
ici je suis handicapé et pourtant je
suis les entreprises n'ont la plupart
préfèrent payer les amendes ce soit
peut-être qu'ils pensent que un
handicapé va avoir peut-être les retards
des dents dans leur travail
est-ce que c'est des choses que du coup
le handicap vous préféré cacher ben oui
je vais pas faire un cachet s'avère que
je fais un cv je mette pas mon handicap
dessus et quand la personne me voient
ils hésitent beaucoup de romans a pas
d'embauché
quelle est la nature de votre handicap
pauli mérite la poliomyélite c'est une
maladie que l'on a donné cent des
naissances
oui j'ai eu à trois ans il consiste en
quoi votre travail
mon travail c'est agence agence est
polyvalent ce plus médiation mais j'ai
fait une formation de l'agent sécurité
pour voir mon diplôme j'ai réussi mon
diplôme en
2015 et j'ai maintenant je savais que je
me déplace chaque caillou public et tout
ça et vous êtes titulaire mais n'ont
encore pas encore vous pensez que vous
allez l'être bientôt je sais pas je suis
le point de vue de dieu je le suivais on
va mettre tous direct diable voilà je
suis handicapé la la
moi je dis que sur le but normand faut
dire la vérité pour travailler en toute
sécurité
il faut dire tu dis pas ben déjà tué en
infraction vous direz on va te donner un
matériel qui te correspond pas déjà et
là-dessus bain soit à l'autre puisqu'ils
plomb durci toi qui plonge je crois que
un message qu'on peut faire passer ces
se former ainsi sur son information au
bon augmenter ses compétences parce que
plus on augmente ses compétences plus on
a des chances de s'insérer dyslexie
dyscalculie et des orthographes i 'cela
montre freiniste m'a dit que c'était la
forme la plus forte on va dire de la
dyslexie
dans mon cas en tout cas après pendant
l'entretien on me demande quel handicap
g et puis j'explique et mais bon après
on me demande est ce que ça va me poser
problème pour tel état qu'on va me
donner et puis bon bah j'explique
comment je peux faire pour pallier à ça
et puis bon bah je veux avec ma tutrice
si elle me donne des documents les
cannes à beaucoup bouger avoir du mal
par exemple
à regarder toutes les informations parce
qu'elle a beaucoup trop du coup ce
qu'elle fait ce qu'elle réduit et est
sûre ligne avec un surligneur pour que
je voie les informations et que je ne
perds pas à charger les informations
pour faire les documents qu'elle me
demande alors au contraire puisque en
fait j'étais accompagné tout au long des
démarches toute ma vie en fait par cap
emploi
donc franchement moi je tenais à leur
merci c'est grâce à vous aujourd'hui que
je suis sur le marché du travail
ils m'ont motivé et mon préparer aux
entretiens
voilà j'ai eu de bons accompagnatrice de
bonnes l'accompagnatrice pardon tout au
long de ma carrière en fait voilà or
effectivement donc mon la signature en
2012 nous étions avec 94% de personnes
en situation de handicap employés au
sein des collectivités en 2013
effectivement on a pu dépasser la barre
des 2% avec le 0 3% en 2014
on a pu noter une augmentation
significative on est arrivé à 2 81 % en
l'augmentation effectivement se confirme
avec un taux d'emploi qui s'élève à 3
809% corps en 2016 on a pu effectivement
approcher les 5 % avec un taux d'emploi
précisément de cas des bulls en
dispensant est aujourd'hui
au moment où effectivement je vous parle
nous envoie je suis nous enregistrons un
taux d'emploi de 6 21% ce qui représente
un effectif
personne alors ça représente un effectif
de deux cent soixante deux agents
porteurs de handicap au sein de la
collectivité
moi j'étais dans une formation avec des
gens d'un centre de formation pour les
gens handicapés y avait toutes sortes de
handicaps
j'en voyais tous les jours et il y avait
même quitté remarquable ah oui moi j'ai
vu des gens qui arrivaient avec la
bouche
les stylos à la bouche et citoyen est
écrit mieux que toi
[Musique]